Her low freak bitches.
So ridiculous.
But um,
women's Bantam weight division is filled
with fucking killers now.
There's so many good fighters.
They're trading titles now.
The main events I love,
that's a big,
big deal.
Women's sports,
you know,
they don't what's definitely a big deal
for the biggest paper.
Have you ever,
I mean obviously it wasn't going to be
of John Jones didn't test positive for
something,
but uh,
because he did,
it's switched around.
Yeah.
So to it yet.
Is he saying what he did?
No,
he's not,
he's not saying anything.
Chill son and leaked the information
during my last podcast so it's out of
his chest.
Shale has leaked out information.
It could be,
is it what he said to me out there?
I had no nothing.
I didn't hear anything.
Had nothing at all talking about,
honestly,
I'm in a weird position cause I don't
think you're supposed to,
I don't think he supposed to.
Anybody's supposed to be talking about
the medical results until like it gets
released.
I don't know how it works.
I really don't.
I'm going to plead in grunts,
plead ignorance all day bridal name.
I think he probably took boner pills
cause that's,
they have all that shit in them.
You know,
like they have boner pills,
have steroids in them that they have.
And I always hitting right now because I
just found at Joe's gas station over
here,
it has like the best,
I've never seen these.
Ryan is known for his love of the boner
pill.
He means what you would call a boner
Con is tour.
He's actually a read blogs about boner
pills and directed me to reviews of
boner pills.
Terrified.
But they,
I mean these things have steroids in
them.
They have a bunch of stuff and if you
party wasn't the last thing he got
busted for cocaine or something.
If you bust,
if you do cocaine,
I had a guys take these because you can
get hard off of having cocaine.
And so if he takes boner pills,
then he's going to attend a little too
much speculation for a person like
believe respect.
Okay.